as gay returns is such a bad show and
there's so much sex and death on there
as well we sought on a little game
I'll give you three names and you have
to tell me which of these characters in
the show as your white Walker would you
marry murder or make out with do you
understand the rules I understand the
rules are you ready to take the marry
murder or makeout challenge okay I'm
ready so as the white Walker would you
marry murder or make out with Cersei
Jaime Lannister and Tywin Lannister I
would murder Jaime Lannister the first
one was thirsty I would make out with
Cersei and the last one I would marry
that match made in heaven
hello yeah I'm all over that for you
there you married murder or make out and
why Catelyn Stark Lord more months and
Mance Rayder the king of north of the
wall say yes
murder him this is just not nice
sometimes I would make out with what was
the first one
yeah Catelyn Stark Catelyn Stark because
she's hot this is very hot I would love
to marry her to marry yeah yeah okay
I'll make out I can see lovely couples
for me here the White Walkers robotnik a
loser it's great stuff cool and one
final work for you we've got oh sure
Samwell Tarly and Hodor married murder
we'll make out oh sure
Samwell Tarly and Hodor saml terima
codes partial rows are short
Hacha murder no I know I and was the
other Mary yes Mary
yes why not maybe couple you know like
both tall as well see look we get
together would be very tall wedding yes
you would you might the wedding we think
dragons and White Walkers some something
hot and something called
to be served to the buffet buffet might
be people we've got some bees and people
what I'll see you keep them well thank
you for accepting on berry murder or
makeout janitor